years of war so the ultimate edition
came out on pc today yes yes and to
specify Windows 10 yeah ok it's only I
don't windows that which means DirectX
12 right is it only available via the
windows 10 store or is the ninja that is
our box copy to be no there's not as now
okay so you had some problems with it
this morning but also the end this
morning but it may have been rectified
what's what's going on so yeah yesterday
on two separate rigs the one at the
office we have what the 980 Titans
triple SLI gtx 980 TI s with very
powerful very powerful with point like
16 gigs of high speed ram or like the
top end I 7c alienware alpha pc or alpha
no I forget whatever their big
triangular piece yes one that looks like
Tutankhamun's Barry though yeah I think
alpha is the steam machine it Rick it
should easily like no problem be able to
run it and I put Ultimate Edition in or
I downloaded it yesterday they download
itself took a long time I don't know how
much that is windows from the windows
and stone yeah there is a known bug with
windows 10 store and it's not just with
gears that when it shows download
progress it shows it like an increment
so you may say like two percent forever
and then jump to like 30 also better
yeah anyway but um yeah and right from
the first cutscene when Marcus is in his
jail cell it was kind of unplayable d
cutscene itself from I remember and from
what I played today should be like 40
seconds yeah I think it took me three
and a half minutes or she'll get through
it because I would keep just chugging
and the audio itself was kind of doing
the same thing we running it on high
settings or died tried it on medium I
tried it on high and Trinity yeah yeah
there is a setting so ambient occlusion
is the thing that simulates the
scattering of light in an environment
and a microsoft adcenter press release
late last night saying like users with
AMD hardware haven't having issues one
ready to rectify that as turn off an
ambient occlusion I asked him about
Nvidia and they say we haven't heard any
problems with that but we were screwing
around a little bit and turned off
ambient occlusion this morning even and
there was also an update for the game
right yeah something some update when I
we had been playing far cry on and so we
the Machine updated something through
Windows 10 and it was running much
better I haven't played on the other rig
lest so I last night at home I was
playing and that was like different set
of problems those were 970 TI's I
believe yeah just one though right yes I
was 9 70 and same problem should still
no different problems uh so it's running
much more smoothly but it was it was uh
essentially screen tearing a lot of it
and I you know I turned on like turned
on and off the anti-aliasing to make
sure wasn't anything specific describing
like pop in and yeah there was a like
odd granular offense right that's yeah
there's a pop in a lot of times the game
is so especially when you're doing those
active reloads that the game you know
set the president for every time I went
to do one of those that it would just
the game would stutter really quick so
it's there all eyes and it was weird it
was only then and then also a few other
times I when I pause the game the
drivers just stopped working and they
were completely updated but I don't know
how much that was I don't know if that
was widespread but right so lots of
problems we don't know if it's been
fixed at this stage it's looking more
optimistic but yeah I'd have to play a
little more about both rigs to kind of
see what the deal is okay so kind of
watch this space at this yeah four
thousand dollar pc is not a good test
case for an average pc route yeah which
is what we've been using on today when
it seemed to be a little bit better so
over the next few days we're gonna keep
an eye on it and see how things improve
cool so is there gonna be a special
review going up for this one than pc
version of we've got that review up my
god got it up this morning will probably
be updating it assuming that performance
issues are fixed if not then it will
remain wonderful one of the get on pc as
i had to drop to a 64 the right in
tissues a seven on xbox one is what you
got back in yeah actually it's
coincidental we're talking about
twilight princess you know a same thing
the still a good game just you know in
retrospect a lot of things have an aged
well yeah i like two and three a lot
more i have played them recently i think
they there's a pretty big leap between
one and two but you know one i was
finding its footing in 2006 and thousand
six it was a great game but i think you
know ten years later just like twilight
princess okay hasn't really aged as well
yeah it was kind of the first of its
kind it wasn't the first cover of a
shooter but it was like the first big
corporation raise the bar for sure raise
the bar there you go yeah raise the roof
is
yeah chin let's go ahead yeah what a
raise idioms do you have in your pocket
uh raised by wolves hey go raise blood
work shows how it works I don't have any
don't I don't look at me may go well if
you have any raised by idioms yourself
please by all means put them in the
comment box below